Jeff Huber: I'm Jeff Huber.
I'm SVP of engineering here at Google, responsible
for ads and aps products.
And on behalf of Women at Google -- the group
-- and the "Talks at Google" series, please
join me in welcoming Padmasree Warrior, the
CTO of Cisco.
>> [Clapping]
Jeff Huber: She'll be speaking on "A Look
at The Future," which includes her perspective
on market and technology transitions that
are changing the nature of work, how we connect,
the future of computing -- including lots
of video and collaboration -- and I bet some
thoughts on Smart Cities as well.
Prior to her role at Cisco, Padrasree was
the CTO of Motorolla.
She joined Motorolla in 1984, rose through
the ranks there to be responsible, to be their
CTO.
And she directed Motorolla Labs, and led a
team of 26,000 engineers.
She's very actively involved in the community
as well, is on the board of the Joffrey Ballet
-- and, being a Chicago native myself, one
of my favorite museums, the Museum of Science
and Industry.
In 2004, she received the National Medal of
Technology, and in 2007, was inducted into
the Women in Information Technology International's
Hall of Fame.
And just last night was recognized by the
Forum for Women Entrepreneurs and Executives
with their Annual Achievement Award, which
is a great accomplishment.
And given that this is a bit of a geeky audience,
Padmasree also recently surpassed one million
Twitter followers, [laughter] and as you'll
see, is far more interesting than Ashton Kutcher
or Oprah Winfrey.
With that, Padmasree Warrior.
>> [Clapping]
Padmasree Warrior: Thanks, Jeff.
That's quite a generous introduction.
Hi, everyone.
It's my great pleasure to be here today.
I know some of the folks at Google have been
working very hard for over a year to get me
here, so I appreciate very much your patience.
And it's actually a great opportunity to share
my perspective on future and kind of treat
this more as a dialogue.
Because I think, as we all know, any vision
we have for the future as time passes becomes
very trite and mundane.
And that is really the power of technology.
Innovation really is the magic that makes
imagination become a reality.
So my goal is not so much just to see beyond
the future, but it's actually to enable it
-- enable it through technology.
And that's why I enjoy my role so much as
the CTO.
So with that, what I want to do is to talk
a little bit about how certain technologies
-- certain technology frameworks -- are really
going to change how and where work gets done
in the future, and also reflect a little bit
on what "connected life" might look like,
and how Cisco and other companies in the technology
industry are working hard to make all of this
a reality, and talk a little bit about the
future of computing as a platform to do many
of these things.
And then, I want to share some views about
what all this means for business -- for leadership.
And, in that context, I'll talk specifically
about women leaders, because that's a topic
near and dear to my heart.
Lastly, about education.
How might education look like in the future?
And hopefully, have lots of time for questions
from the audience in the room and those that
are watching online.
So, you know, if you think about future, one
of the things that we see happening is, more
and more there is a demand for tools and applications
and platforms that enable intercompany collaboration.
So a few years ago -- for those of us that
have been in the industry for a long time
-- a lot of companies and corporations focused
on enabling cross-functional teams and engineers
to work more closely with designers and marketeers.
And really, it was all about How do you get
diverse groups within a company to work together?
And the manufacturing industry probably pioneered
a transition where they started to look beyond
their own walls, and started thinking about
How do you extend business processes to include
suppliers, and not just suppliers from the
point of purchase one step out, but multiple
steps out, and realize that there's a huge
amount of productivity gains that they could
get from this.
And many other verticals are now following
suit.
So what does this mean?
This means now we have to think through developing
enterprise applications that, not just connect
within the enterprise Internet work, but also
go into the cloud and deploy certain applications
from the cloud.
It brings very interesting challenges for
all of us in the industry to do that with
security and interruptability.
Because each enterprise today uses different
platforms to provide the connectivity.
At the same time, increasingly companies are
depending on clusters of experts to get together
and work on critical projects.
And, you know, this is a very interesting
idea also.
At Cisco -- Cisco is a company with about
65,000 or so employees, over $30 billion in
revenues.
We do business in almost every country on
the planet.
And it's a company that's stitched together
with 130 acquisitions over its history of
25 years.
And we just recently did an analysis.
We have close to 250 CEOs in the company.
They all came from some form of an acquisition
or another.
So the challenge is, How do you enable these
experts, these entrepreneurs, to create and
innovate and tap into expertise that's outside
of the walls of the company, right?
And so, the power of being able to do that
is, Experts choose the projects that they
want to work on rather than being assigned
by their boss to go work on a project.
And so, this is a dynamic process and it's
self-forming and improves agility and, in
fact, produces better results.
So at Cisco, the way we drive innovation -- and
we pursue at any time between 30 to 50 market
adjacencies, as we call it, are really a portfolio
of growth opportunities.
And part of my responsibility as the CTO is
to make sure these portfolio growth opportunities
get the oxygen they need to foster the innovation
within the company as well as tap into ideas
outside, right? So we have a program that
we call I-Prize and I-Zone, where we collect
ideas from various parts of the globe and
incorporate that into our own innovation portfolio.
So this notion is very interesting, because
that sort of suggests that, perhaps organizations
will not be organized functionally or in a
structured fashion in the future.
We have to think through How do we make these
more social webs, almost, but in the context
of work.
So, think of the postures of experts concept
to be at the foundation of that.
The next major shift that will change how
work is perceived is, the emergence of millennials.
So, people born after 1975.
Probably some of them may be in this room
today.
And this generation brings with them the notion
that they want to have access to work whenever
they want to work, right?
So I always say this -- and already we do
this -- that the concept of "going to work"
will go away in the future.
We will simply "do work" wherever we are.
And that ties into the next trend, which is
mobility.
Already there's a huge demand for -- and expectation
-- that we will have access to every enterprise
application on any form of device, whether
we are mobile, fixed, or nomadic.
And the access is really not pertinent.
And so, How do we solve that problem?
So, what all of this means to the future of
work is, there's a huge demand for us to create
a platform that now can integrate voice video
and data and provide those capabilities and
applications in a secure, interoperable way,
both from on-premise access as well as in-the-cloud
access, which is big set of challenges, but
lots of room for innovation for all of us
to drive this.
The second area I want to talk about is "Connected
Life.”
And again, you know, here mobility is a huge
factor.
I used to work for a mobile company before
I came to Cisco, and I often used to tell
people, "Every second on planet Earth there
are four babies born.
Every second on planet Earth there are 32
mobile phones sold.”
And so, the impact of what mobile communications
is going to do to help people get connected
and communicate is just -- we probably haven't
even scratched the surface yet.
And I actually believe that the term "mobile
Internet" will be redundant in the future,
just like we don't say "mobile e-mail.”
We just say "e-mail," and we expect to get
it wherever we are.
Internet access will be very pervasive, and
hopefully seamless between whether we are
mobile or whether we have a fixed access.
The second interesting thing in the "Connected
Life" area -- and Cisco is driving a lot of
this -- is, video.
Video, we believe, will be a killer ap in
the future -- everything from user-generated
video content.
We acquired recently a company called Pure
Digital, which makes the Flip Video Cam -- high-density,
video camcorder, if you have one.
And it's now become my favorite toy.
And we're trying to figure out, How do we
bring that capability into the enterprise
phase, all the way to high-density, high-resolution,
multipoint telepresence?
And then, with the availability of on-demand
content now, consumers' expectation has shifted.
The debate is not really about content ownership
anymore.
How do you consume content more in a community
and make that a more community experience.
So we recently launched an initiative to wire
up sports' stadiums -- Dallas Cowboy Stadium,
and a couple of other stadiums.
And people often wonder, "What is Cisco doing
wiring stadiums up?”
And the intent is not just to provide an immersive
video experience in the stadium, but we are
working on, How do you extend that into the
home?
So, from your home you can have an immersive
experience as if you're in the stadium watching
your favorite sport.
So there is a lot we can do to sort of make
content consumption much more interactive
and much more of a social experience in the
future.
The other change that's driving "Connected
Life," I would say, is more recent.
Probably this shift we've seen in the last
six months or so.
And it's probably one of the good things that's
come out of the economic crisis the world's
going through, and has gone through.
And this is the fact that, there's now a lot
of stimulus money from many different governments
around the world to think about how technology
can be applied to traditional protocols like
healthcare, like transportation, like energy.
So a lot of recent movement in Smart Grid.
For example, Smart Connected Cities, Smart
Buildings, How do you make buildings much
more energy efficient, and What role does
IP Networking play to make that happen?”
Same thing in health care.
We are working on -- we have telepresence
capability.
How do you extend that to promote and make
remote health care available, where a doctor
can interface with a patient when proximity
is not needed to provide health care to remote
locations where maybe there is no physical
medical facility available, but we can provide
that through telepresence?
So lots of things going on in, I would say,
what I would call "Lifestyle Optimization,"
applying technology, and what we traditionally
thought of IT mostly as a B to B, but in different
protocols, going into healthcare, sports,
education, etc.
Lastly, Computing -- and probably this is
something you all know more than I do.
Some of us have been in this industry long
enough to see the evolution from the 60's,
from mainframes to minicomputers to PCs, more
recently, the web.
And we believe the next evolution will be
to Cloud Computing.
But we have to help enterprises make the transition,
because they already have a lot of investments
that they've made in data centers.
And, How do you help take advantage of their
investments companies have made with virtualization
so that you can scale Cloud Computing to become
more of a marketplace with workload portability,
federation, and security as to move data between
the Cloud and apply with data center, for
instance.
So that, we believe, is three big shifts that
we will see: Future of work, future of Connected
Life, and Computing.
And then, you can kind of think and say, "Okay,
what does this mean to the Internet?" Wherever
we go -- wherever there is a platform for
the next ten to 15 years.
And first, I want to look backwards and say,
What did the Internet really allow us to do,
or What did we really focus on as an industry
in the last maybe ten, 15, 20 years, right?
The network really focused on providing data
transport.
It was really about moving small bits of data
from point A to point B.
And e-mail was probably the killer ap in the
first phase of the Internet.
And it was really a messaging platform.
We all used it mostly for asynchronous messaging,
using e-mail initially.
And the entire industry back then was focused
on optimizing price-performance ratios.
So MIPS and megabits were the two metrics
we all focused on.
Fastest network and most bandwidth that you
could push traffic through.
And really didn't worry about things like
power consumption, cooling water requirements,
data center footprint.
Those things were all afterthoughts.
We didn't worry about those things.
And essentially, applications were vertically-integrated
with infrastructure.
So if you had to deploy a new application
and enterprise, you had to deploy new infrastructure
with it.
So what we believe will happen in the second
phase of the Internet, or -- as I call it
-- the "Next Internet," is experiences now
have to scale almost exponentially as billions
more devices and billions more people connect
to the network.
Which means, now we have to think about the
network being more than data transport.
It has to be enable media experience.
We've already seen this happen to the music
industry.
Not too long ago, -used to buy pieces of furniture
to store physical forms of music.
And you know?
Now, I have this little thing that looks like
a dresser.
It's camouflaged like a dresser, and if you
open it, there's drawers to store CDs in.
It's become an antique now.
I don't know what to do with it.
You know, so that how we consume music is
dramatically changed by the Internet.
And the same thing I think will happen with
video next.
And collaboration I already talked about.
The challenge we have is, How do you develop
an enterprise-class collection platform and
bring things that are now in the consumer
web with -- we just talked about Twitter,
and Jeff mentioned I have over a million followers
on Twitter.
I love Twitter.
I think it's just a great application.
Allows me to have conversations that I normally
wouldn't have in my normal course of the day,
and allows me to actually meet many new people
on Twitter.
And so, How do you make those concepts come
into the enterprise and make them more robust
to drive productivity in the enterprise?
So that's really what I mean by "collaboration
enterprise platform" -- to engage in realtime
interactive communications and create content
and create intellectual property together,
both by participation from outside the corporation's
boundaries and inside -- the talent that's
inside the corporation.
Last thing, sustainability.
And here kind of think about two areas.
One is, How do we apply Internet principles
and IP networking to improve building's energy
efficiency, city's energy efficiency, etc.
The other area is, How do you actually develop
IT itself to be more energy efficient?
How do we build routing switching, data center
products to be much more energy efficient?
So we focused on both those areas.
And lastly, Virtualization and Cloud Computing,
How does that change compute, right?
But a prerequisite for all this is broadband
penetration.
And I think that's where we're lagging behind
in several parts of the world, including the
United States.
And data says that actually ten percent increase
in broadband penetration in developing markets
drives GDP up by 1.4 percent.
So, I think the challenge we all have in the
industry is to drive that forward and make
sure there is broadband available, so that
we can deploy a lot of these technologies
and make the planet more smarter and greener.
So at Cisco, we are focused in four areas
that drive our technology strategy very broadly.
The first area is video.
Second is collaboration.
Third is Smart, Connected Communities, and
I'll tell you a little bit about what we mean
by that.
Virtualization and Cloud Computing.
So, if you look at all of these, virtually,
a lot of these opportunities drive network
traffic.
They drive bandwidth, and they drive innovation
on the network.
And that's our agenda.
And so, really you know, we expect that annual
IP traffic will reach two-thirds of a zettabite,
or 667 exabites, by the end of this year.
So, if you think about it, by 2013 -- so about
four years from now -- we will see global
IP traffic increase almost five-fold from
where we are in 2009.
That's really mind-boggling if you think about
it.
And on the consumer Internet today, about
a third of the traffic is driven by Internet
video.
So, thanks to YouTube and Hulu and others,
and Internet video itself in 2013 will be
almost 700 times bigger than the entire U.S.
Internet backbone was in the year 5000.
So that was in 13 years.
And so, lots going on that will drive a lot
of traffic onto the network.
The other interesting data point is actually
mobile data.
By 2013, 62 percent of mobile data traffic
will be video.
So a lot of applications that we can create
and think about creating that will drive that
traffic.
So we love video, all forms of video in any
form, and we're making big investments.
You probably saw today Cisco announced our
intention to acquire Tandberg, which makes
desktop video conferencing.
We already are a leader in very, high-end
telepresence.
And I talked about Flip, so we are looking
at video as an end-to-end architecture, everything
from user-generated video to high-density,
high-resolution video.
Smart Connected Communities -- I want to talk
about a little bit.
This is, you know really, I believe that we
will evolve to what I call the "Industrialization
of the Internet.”
And so here, the challenge really is, How
do you connect the cyber world with the physical
world?
So it's using sensor networks, perhaps.
And not just actually connecting "people to
people," but "people to things" and "things
to things.”
And this has been talked about for a number
of years.
We've always talked about the Internet of
Things.
But what is really driving an acceleration
these days in this area is the rapid urbanization
of the planet.
50 percent of the world's population by the
end of 2009 will live in cities.
And these cities add roughly 180,000 people
every day.
That's like creating two new Tokyos every
year.
And we expect that, by the year 2050, there
will be a hundred new cities with over a million
people each.
And, in one sense it's good, because a lot
of the consumption happens in these cities,
but at the same time, you know, cities consume
roughly 75 percent of the energy today, and
they produce 80 percent of the emissions.
So the challenge we have is, How do we enable
these cities to be smarter?
And we are launching pilots in South Korea
in cities like Icheon and Songdong where we
are helping them build Smart Cities where
the network actually becomes a platform for
enabling urban services, so where you can
get information about traffic on your mobile
device.
We're enabling buses to have information about
traffic congestion, and How do you route traffic,
and doing things like that.
We're also working on making buildings smarter
by connecting HVAC systems with IP networks,
so that you can bring those things onto a
same platform.
We acquired a company called Richards-Zeta
that has middleware capabilities that allows
us to do that, and we are bringing more intelligence
from the switching and routing into interconnecting
the HVAC onto a single platform that can be
managed through software.
Smart Grid is another area that's very interesting,
and we think that there will be 82 percent
increase roughly in the energy demands globally
by the year 2020.
So, in the next 20 years or so roughly.
And DOE -- U.S. Department of Energy -- estimates
that just modernization of the U.S. grids
alone will help us save roughly 50 to 100
billion dollars over the next 20 years or
so.
So Smart Grids, if deployed properly, has
the capability to reduce peak loads by almost
15 percent annually.
And so, if you translate that, what that means
is, in the U.S.
alone over the next 20 years, if we deployed
Smart Grids, we would be able to save the
need -- or eliminate the need really -- for
almost a hundred large coal-fired, power plants.
So that's tremendous.
That's almost like taking 30 million automobiles
off the road.
So again, Smart Grid is another area where
we can think about, essentially our focus
is, How do you enable intelligent communication
between power-generation, transmission stations
and home, connecting back into smart metering
at home or commercial buildings?
And so, lots of exciting things.
And fundamentally, I believe that if you look
forward ten years or so, six of the major
sectors will look very different from how
we have been in the past.
You know, that's health care, transportation,
energy, public services perhaps, you know,
IT or communications itself, and how technology
gets deployed, etc.
So, you know, there's a lot of change going
on, which then brings us to the question of,
How will business look like in the future?
And here, I'm speculating, so I'm really open
to a dialogue with you.
I think really successful businesses in the
future have to be able to operate on multiple
dimensions.
And I think many of us actually faced this
challenge recently.
We have to innovate, and we have to focus
on operational excellence.
In the past, it was okay to do one or the
other.
I mean, there were companies that prided themselves
on being very innovative, and there were companies
that prided themselves on being operationally
really good.
And you know, they could get the maximum operating
margins out just by squeezing costs and so
forth.
And more and more, we are finding you have
to do both.
And that, I think, brings up an interesting
challenge for all of us.
And the other interesting thing is, we have
to have global scale, because it is a connected
world and economies are connected -- as we
found out recently as well.
But you have to have agility at the same time
along with the global scale, and How do we
do that?
And the other thing that's interesting.
I just read recently a report that said, high
school students or actually, even middle school
students or kids between the ages of 13 to,
I think, 19.
And there was a survey that was done, and
almost 75 percent of them said that they do
not want to work for a big company.
So you can kind of think of this environment
in the future where there will probably be
all these little start-ups.
Or small companies, right?
And so, What is the notion of a big company
anymore, and How will that change?
What does that mean to business?
Which brings me to, How will leadership change
in the future?
And I spoke last night about -- in the context
of women's leadership -- and maybe this is
more of my perspective as a woman leader,
but I think it applies broadly to leaders
as well.
You know, traditionally leadership was about
commanding and making decisions.
I had a team of 26,000 engineers in my previous
job, and it was great power.
If I said, "Do this," and I could feel like
everybody would do it.
But I think, more and more, leadership is
about influence.
It's, How do you get companies to change direction
or Industry to change direction or Government
to change direction?
And that means leaders have to now figure
out, How do you expand your sphere of influence?
It's not just what you control, but it's,
How do you influence outside your boundaries?
And this is where a lot of the social networking
tools help us.
I think Twitter -- I spoke last night about
how it helps me expand my sphere of influence.
This is a skill leaders didn't have to worry
about a few years ago.
In fact, leaders prided themselves about being
very private.
We were told, "You can't say some things in
public." "Don't say that.”
PR always told us, "Don't do that," "Don't
say this.”
And so, now we have to figure out, "Well,
say it." but "How do you say it?" What do
you say?
And, What not to say?
And, How do you -- the fact that you belong
to multiple communities is a strength, and
that's another area where you can expand your
sphere of influence, right?
For example, I belong to a community of engineers.
I belong to a community of Silicon Valley
leaders.
I belong to a community of women.
I belong to a community of working mothers.
I went to Cornell, so I belong to a Cornell
Alumni community.
There's various communities we belong to,
and more and more, a challenge for all of
us, as we become leaders is, How do you leverage
these communities, and, In what way is it
appropriate to bring some of these communities
to overlap in what you are doing?
So those are some new leadership skills that
we would have to learn.
The second skill is about collaboration.
And this is interesting, because I actually
think of collaboration as being very different
from teamwork or "consensus-driven committees"
as we used to call them, right?
You know, it's not -- collaboration doesn't
necessarily mean teamwork and everybody gets
along and does things.
It actually means you're okay in sharing an
idea before it's fully formulated.
You have an idea, and you want to share that
so other people can add -- other experts can
add -- to that idea to make it stronger.
And, How do we do that?
What's the right way to do it?
And, What's the most appropriate to do it
quickly, so that you are not forever gathering
input.
At some point you have to move on.
So collaboration -- how to collaborate.
What it means, I think, is another leadership
skill that we would have to garner.
And the third is really, being more than just
being a pioneer or a trailblazer.
And again, this is in the context of women
that I talked about last night at this forum
for women entrepreneurs and executives.
When I started in the industry almost 20 years
ago, there were very few women -- in engineering,
especially, and in leadership positions.
So there were women that were considered to
be trailblazers and pioneers, who sort of
formed the way, and we were told we had to
be different.
Women were told they had to dress different,
act different, speak different, maybe more
like a man, dress like a man.
I think more and more, what people really
appreciate is authenticity.
Leadership is all about being real, who you
are.
So I encourage all the women to really be
women, and be successful by the fact that
you are a woman leader and a woman engineer,
or a technical or marketing expert, or whatever
it is.
So I think this notion of trying to be different
or being a pioneer by being different is going
to change in the future.
So I think those are some things that I think
about how leaders of the future, some of the
challenges that they will have to deal with.
Which brings me next to education.
And this might be controversial, but I actually
think there's a big difference between education
and learning.
And if you think about it, right?
The famous Einstein quote about -- I forget
the exact quote, but it's something like,
"It's a miracle that curiosity survives formal
education.”
And in a way, it's so true, because now content
is available.
And so, the fact that education is really
about teaching content has to change.
It has to become more about How do you teach
how to learn, because students these days
can access content anywhere.
So, What do you do with that content?
How do you actually make -- my view is education
is more discreet, it has a beginning and an
end in some ways, whereas learning is continuous.
We have to teach our children how to learn
continuously.
And, What do you do with all this information
that's available? And, How do you create something
with it?
So I think education perhaps will also take
on a new meaning in the future and become
more about learning -- I hope, anyway.
So I'll stop there and take questions from
all of you if you have any.
I think that's my last step.
And I think there's a microphone on the side.
>> [pause]
>> [Laughter]
Q I go to the microphone so people can hear
me.
You mentioned really needing to drive innovation
and operational excellence, which has been
not historically viewed as necessarily complementary.
Agree that that is the necessity and reality
of today.
How do you think about that with your teams?
And as a leader at Cisco applying that across
Cisco?
Padmasree Warrior: That's a great question.
It's a very tough thing, because right now,
I think innovators pride themselves as not
being process-driven.
They don't want to follow process.
Process is evil.
And people that are good at process think
of innovators as being these crazy people
that just keep coming up with ideas and they
don't know what to do with them.
You know, and I said as a company we were
pursuing 30 adjacencies, which is a lot for
a big company.
And each of those we expect to be a billion-dollar
opportunity almost.
So that's where we expect our next $30 billion
of growth to come from.
And we think we have to go to 50.
And so, one of the challenges is, "Okay, What
do you do?
How do you know which ones of these are right?”
And "How do you know which ones you want to
accelerate and doubledown on, and which ones
you want to slow down?”
So I actually came up with this methodology
with some of my peers at Cisco.
We've taken Geoffrey Moore's Chasm Model -- if
you are familiar with that -- which talks
about technology at option life cycle, and
there's a chasm and there's prechasm, post-chasm.
And we've actually taken that, and most of
the growth opportunities, if you think about
it, fall in the prechasm mode.
You know, when you're an innovator, you're
thinking about something that's still early.
You probably don't know if there's going to
be a market yet.
And so, how you measure that is going to be
very different than something that's going
to be more of a mature business.
And we have come up with ways, by allowing
different types to measure progress on something
that's innovative, but there is still measurement.
And you still have to.
You know, I tell people this, "You don't graduate
with your Ph.D. just because you're brilliant.
You still have to defend your thesis.
There's a process.
And there's a gate you have to go through.”
Similarly, if you're asking for funding within
a company or from an outside company, you
still have to hit some metrics.
And so, we're trying to put some of those
metrics in the discipline, but at the same
time allowing people the freedom to create
and come up with great ideas.
Q Hi. Congratulations on your award last night.
I was lucky among a few of us to hear you,
and it was really just a fantastic speech.
Sometimes you hear these speeches, and they're
galvanizing.
That was one. So thank you.
I'm curious about your Twitter experience,
if I can do that in a clear, limiting way.
We struggle all the time with quality, at
the scale of the Internet, with the information
that's managed out there.
It's impossible to manage at our scales, but
at the personal scale, when you have a million
followers, how do you crowd source in meaningful
ways?
You mention that you got a lot of value from
that.
How do you manage that, I guess?
Padmasree Warrior: Yeah. It's a great question.
You know, in the beginning, when I first started,
I was one of the earlier adopters of Twitter.
I think, when I started, there were very few
people on Twitter.
And at the time, I felt like I could say anything
I wanted to, because nobody was really reading
it.
And then, all of a sudden, you find out that
everybody's reading it, right?
I recognize that Wall Street Journal is following
me, and everybody else is following me.
So now, you know, then you realize, "Oops.
Maybe I have to be more careful what I say.”
But actually what I've found to be most useful
for me is, when I am thinking about a concept,
for example, collaboration.
I was preparing to give a keynote at one of
the large conferences, and I was thinking
about the future of collaboration, What does
it mean to the enterprise? And I said, "Okay,
let me use a collaboration platform to ask
that question.”
I asked people, "What are your five predictions
for the future of collaboration?”
I got a ton of input from people everywhere.
I mean, people in the industry, out of the
industry, analysts, you know, just people
that are users of the technology.
And I gathered all that input, and I think
this is a room for an ap on -- somebody has
to create for Twitter, if somehow you can
get -- today it's manually, you know, I gathered
all the information, and I had one of our
smart engineers at Cisco develop a piece of
software for me where it's tracked and it
creates for me, What are the words that are
appearing most frequently?
So things like "mobile.”
Things like "making it more productive and
robust.”
Those types of things came up in this prediction.
Which in turn, influenced my view, and therefore,
our strategy for Cisco.
So I think to me, that those kinds of uses
are the biggest benefit I get.
I also write haiku on Twitter that has nothing
to do with my work, just because I like writing
haiku.
And now, I have all these people that love
poetry following me on Twitter.
So, I mean, I think it's just -- the fact
that it's so easy and simple, and you have
to keep it to 140 characters, in a way forces
you to be really crisp about your point, and
the input you get is also likewise pretty
crisp.
So in a way I use it both to relax, share
my personal thoughts, as well as share things
that relate to work.
I have in a way become a channel for Cisco's
marketing.
Now, I get tweets from our Cisco marketing
people saying, "Hey, can you please tweet
this?”
And I send back saying, "Isn't this your job?”
So it's actually become more fun now.
>> [pause]
Q Hi. Thanks for coming.
I read a few years ago that John Chambers
was saying that learning is going to be -- he
made a rounding error in a traffic, and you
talked about education -- how that's going
to change.
How do you see the role of technology companies
in driving that change in education, and how
do you see that happening?
Padmasree Warrior: In education?
Q In education, yeah.
Especially in higher education, like four
years, a degree, like Ph.D.'s.
How do you see that changing?
Padmasree Warrior: Yeah. I think there is
a lot, and I think this is just emerging.
You know, one of the things we are doing -- I
guess several things we are doing -- one of
the things we are doing more to actually just
to increase the level of education in primary
schools and schools in general in developing
countries is deploying things like "telepresence"
to promote teachers to access students remotely,
and get access to education, right?
Because I think that the advantage with something
like telepresence is that it's a very immersive
presence.
You see the person as if they're there.
They're life-size, and they're just right
there.
So we're doing that type of thing.
We also have things like Networking Academies
where Cisco actually deploys these academies
worldwide.
And I forget the number of people that go
through this.
It's a very high number.
It's something like 300-, 400,000 people that
have graduated through these networking academies
where we train people to actually manage the
network, operate the network -- about networking
actually.
So we do specific domain expertise.
Now, we are thinking about, "Okay, we have
that infrastructure.
We've trained people on networking.
What else could we use it for?”
So recently, with the Obama administration,
we used our networking academy infrastructure
in Michigan to help retrain the work force
to do additional things.
So we are doing that type of thing, which
is more -- I guess you could say it's -- vocational
education.
But in higher education, how that'll get transformed.
We have to think through, you know, just like
we're thinking about virtual health care How
do you get this content -- I think one of
the challenges we all have in the industry
-- there is a lot of information now, right?
I think we've all made that happen.
And now, the challenge is, How do you provide
relevance to that information?
How do you connect people, community, and
information with this triangle?
How do you provide relevance to that? And
so, that's one of the things we're working
on in researchwise.
And I think if you do that, then we can think
about education being very different where
I was talking earlier about.
Perhaps you can tell the students there's
relevance to these sorts of information, and
they can go access that.
And then, the education is really about, What
do you do with that piece of information?
Q Hi. I'm a product manager in one of the
research teams here, and one of the things
I think about a lot is "productizing research.”
I'm curious to hear your views on, What are
some effective ways to accelerate that research
to product? Specifically, because Cisco in
general I see as a company that does R&D by
acquisition for the most part.
And from your experience in Motorolla, I'm
curious to hear what do you think works and
what doesn't?
Padmasree Warrior: Yeah. That's a great question.
You know, I think they're very different models.
When I was at Motorolla, we had a research
lab with close to 800 people that were doing
essentially, I would say, pretty fundamental
research, working with universities.
And then, we had a very disciplined way of
transferring that into commercialization.
Cisco here, right?
We have a very small focus on research.
Mostly, we fund universities to do the research.
The philosophy at Cisco is that, We let the
people that are really good at doing research
do the research, and we will either acquire
or create, focus more on developing.
But we do tap into -- Cisco uses what I call
-- I was talking about this earlier, this
notion of I-Prize and I-Zone -- very effectively,
where we post a problem and let innovators
bid on it, and we have a competition and whoever
wins, and the competition, I mean, it's judged
by independent judges, not just Cisco teams.
We have VCs and people from academia participate
in that.
And the winning idea gets $250,000 seed-funding
from Cisco.
And we usually negotiate something for the
intellectual property, and so forth.
So we do it that way at Cisco.
But I think -- to answer your question about
some of the things from overall my experience
about research -- it's very important to do
research, because that's how you discover
things, you know, which is mostly in the invention
phase.
The challenge is, How do you translate those
inventions to innovations, right?
And this is where you have to tie very closely
with, What is the market transition going
to be?
I think it's very critical.
One of the big challenges in bringing things
to market is actually catching the transition
at the right time.
You know, timing is very important, because
you can be too early in the market and have
a failed product, or you can be too late,
at which point, you won't make very good margins.
And so, you have to get the timing right.
And the biggest challenge that I felt when
I was leading research organizations is getting
the timing right on when you take something
out of research and move it more into product
development, and How does that hand-off happen?
And so, to do that, really, you need to have
input from multiple directions, right?
You have to have a feel for, What are the
global trends in the market dynamics? And
sometimes it's hard to predict.
That's, like I was talking about, the "Internet
of Things" has been in research phase almost
for 10, 15 years.
People have been working on sensor networks.
But it's only recently, we've seen commercial
need for it, mainly driven by Smart Grid.
And the Smart Grid demand happened because
energy has become a problem.
Now, there's stimulus money going into it.
So other factors change that.
So somehow, you have to have a feel and your
finger on the pulse of the changes that are
going on in the marketplace.
And whether you do that in the research organization,
or you work with other parts of Google that
does that, I think that's very critical.
Q Hi. So you've worked at two very interesting
and hallmark technology companies at Motorolla
and Cisco.
Just curious your observations on the relative
places, sort of cultural differences, the
corresponding management, leadership challenges
that those present?
And then also, you've made the transition
from the Midwest to Silicon Valley, and your
observations on life and business differences
between those two?
Padmasree Warrior: Right. I tell people I'm
lucky I lived in Chicago and Palo Alto, two
of the best places in the world to be.
You know?
So yeah, very different companies Motorolla
and Cisco in some ways, but very similar in
other ways.
I think the similarities are that both are
very global with large footprints across the
globe.
And, you know, I consider myself a global
citizen.
I love being part of a global company.
So, those are the common things.
Both very heavily engineering driven.
And I'm an engineer, so I love that.
I think the main difference is that, Motorolla
is probably more of a consumer company, mainly
because of the handset business.
And Cisco is much more of an enterprise-driven
company, although we have a big push into
consumer and other areas, which means that
the, How you sell and How you go to market
are very different in both companies.
Cisco has a very superb sales process.
I would say one of the best I have seen in
any company.
Our sales teams are amazingly good.
And it's great to have them backing you when
you're meeting with customers.
And this is something I love doing -- the
customer-facing interaction, which Motorolla
didn't have so much, because we sold mostly
to carriers, and you know? And it's not so
much direct-selling into consumers or into
customers.
So different from that perspective.
Also, Cisco is a much newer company.
Motorolla is almost 80 years old now, I think,
and Cisco is about 25 years old.
Actually, this year is I think, our 25th anniversary.
So I think that, in itself, brings very different
nuances.
As we were talking about earlier, Cisco is
a company that's made up of acquisitions.
So there's a very heavy, entrepreneurial spirit
in the company, just because it's a collection
of little companies in a way.
But the culture at Cisco is very family-focused.
We sort of, John Chambers always talks about
this, and he calls it the "Cisco Family.”
And even when he was interviewing me to come
to Cisco, and we talked almost for a year
before I finally said yes.
I think Randy shared this story last night
at FWE, at the event.
But, you know, when you say "Cisco is a family"
it kind of sounds corny a little bit.
But in a way, it's true.
There is the notion that, "We compete outside
the company, and we work together inside the
company" which is very powerful.
I think this is sort of like the foundation
for collaboration and the clusters of experts
that I was talking about.
Moving from Chicago to Palo Alto, there are
no winters here, which is great.
I think you can't beat the weather in California.
That's great. And really, I feel like this
is the pulse of a lot of things that are related
to technology and innovation.
Just having this opportunity to talk to people
like you is something that is -- for some
reason -- not as much there in the Midwest,
which is surprising.
Great schools there.
University of Chicago, Northwestern, Urbana
Champaign.
Two national labs, Fermi and Argonne.
So a lot of tech gets created, but probably
more in the invention area rather than in
the innovation area.
So it's, in a way, that's another change.
But, you know, I've been coming.
I've been in the semiconductor industry a
long time.
So I feel like I have been coming here all
the time, but now, I have finally moved here.
So I think this has been a slow transition,
maybe over a long number of years rather than
an abrupt transition.
Q So I was going to ask you a similar question
as Jeff's, but maybe a follow on.
Just around some of the personal career choices
you've made, and going from a very large company
to another very large company.
And it's interesting parallel in Google.
We're not Cisco.
We're not Motorolla.
But like, we are at a very different stage
of our growth, and how you've thought about
your career path and the size of the company
you've decided to join?
Padmasree Warrior: Yeah, actually, you know,
I don't know that the size of the company
is as much of a factor, because all big companies
start small, and they grow to become big.
And it's kind of an interesting dichotomy,
you know?
All small companies want to be big, and all
big companies want to be small.
It's kind of a weird thing.
But I think some things apply, whether it's
a big company or a small company, right?
The ability to get things done and the ability
to figure out How do you go after something?
I mean, those are the same whether you're
in a big company or in a small company.
So I think the career choices I have made,
I have mostly probably have to do with looking
for an exciting opportunity where you can
make a difference, rather than whether it's
a big company or a small company.
And I think that means -- and as I was talking
about last night -- you kind of have to step
out of your comfort zone.
And that's what I have done.
You know, I mean, I spoke last night.
I'm originally from India.
I grew up in India in a small town in the
southern part of India and decided to do engineering
in the northern part of India.
And I left my home when I was sixteen.
And went to New Delhi to do engineering at
IIT, which is one of the hard-core, male-dominated
engineering schools in India.
And my first day of registration after I registered,
I discovered there were five women in a class
of 250.
And I told this story.
I called my dad the next day, and said "I
want to come home." And he said, "It's too
late.
You decided to go there.
Now, you stay there.”
And I thought he was like the meanest dad
in the whole world back then.
I thought I was very clever, and I knew how
to get around this problem.
So I called my mom.
And then, I told her how much I was missing
her cooking.
Now, I have a teenager now, and I know if
he called me and said he was missing my cooking,
I would have him home on the next flight.
But my mom had more sense than that, I think.
She said, "You stay in school; I'll send you
food.”
And so, I ended up finishing my engineering
school.
And so, that was the first time I moved out
of my comfort zone.
And then, I left India to come to the U.S.
to go to graduate school.
I went to Cornell, did my Masters in chemical
engineering, and we were talking earlier about,
"How you go from chemical engineering to being
CTO of Cisco?”
Yeah. So I finished my degree in chemical
engineering at Cornell, and I started in the
semiconductor industry as an engineer -- as
a line engineer actually -- and then, worked
up to become the CTO for Motorolla, semiconductor
business.
And then from there, I went to run a business
which had no technology.
It was all operations, managing supply chain
costs, and taking beatings from customers
every other day, because shipments didn't
happen or something.
And then, I became CTO for Motorolla.
So the point is that, I think, as you look
through your career opportunities and your
growth opportunities as a leader or personal
growth, I think it's to make those transitions
and use those transitions as opportunities
where you can derive a lot of growth.
And that can happen in a small company, big
company, personal life, you know, where you
go through a lot of growth when change happens
in your life.
So, how do you take all of that which defines
you, who you are as a leader and as a person.
Q Congratulations first on your award last
night.
I function as a project manager here at Google,
and one thing that came to my mind is, you
were talking about how processes and innovation
are not necessarily considered as going hand
in hand.
So, how have you managed to integrate the
two together, and what are the models that
have worked at Cisco -- especially given the
next phase of Internet that you are working
on?
Padmasree Warrior: Processing, and what was
the other thing?
Q Innovation.
Padmasree Warrior: Okay. Great question. Yeah.
I mean I think this is something that's my
job.
You know, what I'm asked to do is, How do
you apply process to innovation?
So all the engineers sort of hate me.
But, you know, I keep telling them I think
the advantage of having a process, but the
process has to be flexible.
I don't think you want to do process for process'
sake.
I think you have to think about, How do you
use the process to help people accelerate
what they're working on?
Right? So the way we've been able to develop
that is to sort of look at, you know, the
30 or 50 ajacencies that we are pursuing.
And they vary -- everything from putting a
router in space to using video as the next
big architecture, right?
One is very big, one is a very niche opportunity.
Highly technically challenging to think about
routers in space, and they require very different
kinds of metrics.
And so, the process has to be such that, it's
really flexible to allow that diversity that
innovators need and the room they need to
create.
And it's not about -- you shouldn't measure
them on Did you make a mistake, and How many
mistakes you made.
It's not defects that count, right?
It's not the traditional quality metric.
But it's, What do you do when you make a mistake,
and How do you -- when you find that you have
an experiment and it didn't yield the results
you were expecting, that's still a result.
And so, you have to accept that as a success
and go to the next thing.
So it's actually having that type of flexibility
in the process, I think, is very important.
Otherwise, you get very bureaucratic and bogged
down and nothing ever gets done.
Q So I have a question.
I think earlier you mentioned that a lot of
young professionals are preferring to work
for a smaller company versus a bigger company.
What do you think companies like Google or
Cisco can do to retain and attract, you know,
talented youth to come and work for their
companies?
I imagine these are the type of people who
have the entrepreneurship and innovation to
really help make any company great.
And so, it seems like it would be important
to attract or retain them.
Padmasree Warrior: Yeah. This was actually
a report I had read that talked about how
schools students -- when asked what they want
to do -- almost 80 percent of them or something
said they don't want to work for a big company.
They want to work for little companies with
few people, which made me think, "Well, what
does that mean to companies, right?
In the future, How will they operate?”
So that's kind of where I was quoting that
data from.
What I think we can do, and what we should
do is, sort of create that agility within
a big company.
Big companies, by the way, have a lot of advantages,
right?
And there was an article in The Economist
recently that talked about how, "Big is Back.”
I think when times get tough, having scale
helps.
Then being part of a big company is very attractive,
because you know you have cash, you have very
high margins, and the business is not going
to go away, and you can take the hit for a
few months or a few years and come back.
So there's definite advantages to scale, but
we have to combine the agility and the flexibility
with the scale.
And I think this is a generational shift that
we will see.
As kids that are growing up -- I have a teenage
son, and to him e-mail is dead.
I mean dead.
If I e-mail him, I have to text him or post
an update on his Facebook saying, "I've sent
you an e-mail, please go read it.”
And he always asks me, "Mom, why do you leave
me a voice mail on my mobile phone?
I know I have a missed call, and I know you
called me.
I'll call you back.”
He never checks his voice mail, which is very
frustrating to me, because I grew up with
e-mail and voice mail.
So I think this notion.
I mean, what they require is very different,
so we have to figure out what motivates them.
It's the flexibility, it's the ability to
"do work" not necessarily to "go to work.”
And, How do you enable that to happen?
I think those kinds of things -- we have to
give them that flexibility yet be attached
to a more stable entity, perhaps, which could
be attractive.
>> Maybe a last question.
You mentioned your interest in poetry and
sharing your haikus on Twitter.
Springing this on you a bit.
Any chance you have one you'd like to share?
>> [Laughter]
Padmasree Warrior: I'll probably write one
tonight.
>> Okay. Write one tonight and dedicate it
to Women at Google.
Padmasree Warrior: All right. I will do that.
Thank you.
>> So, thank you very much, Padmasree.
>> [Clapping]